so one of the arguments we hear coming
from the new type of atheist is run
something like this when I was a child I
believed in Santa Claus when I was a
child I believed in the Tooth Fairy but
then one day I grew up and I realized
that Santa Claus doesn't exist I
realized that the Tooth Fairy doesn't
exist
and in the same manner one day I grew up
and I realized that God doesn't exist
and usually God in this in this type of
formulation is referred to as something
like a sky daddy or a sky fairy
something at disparaging in that manner
now I've always found that line of
argumentation rather funny because to me
it seems completely absurd to say that
Santa Claus doesn't exist because
obviously Santa Claus exists
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
there are Santa Clauses everywhere at
Christmas there are guys who dress up as
Santa Claus
there are Santa Claus decoration
ornaments we have stories we have songs
we have all these things which celebrate
Santa Claus and so it is it is it is
patently absurd to say that Santa Claus
does not exist now there are certain
things that don't exist for example a
square circle or dry water now those
things are impossible they do not exist
but Santa Claus definitely exists now
the question we need to ask is if Santa
Claus exists in what manner does Santa
Claus exist and I think that asking
oneself that question of how it is that
Santa Claus exists can maybe help
certain people understand the manner in
which we say that God exists that is
there are things that exist that are not
at the level of my coffee cup you know
that are not at the level of my pencil
or at the level of a rock or at the
level of a concrete you know thing that
you that you can hold in your hands and
say this is it there are things which
exists at different levels of being and
that that don't have as contained let's
say contained bodies okay and you can
say that about concepts it's like love
exists but you can't you can't put it in
a bottle you can't put it in a box but
it still exists okay and actually let's
say Santa Claus exists in a much more
immediate manner than something like
love because we know what Santa Claus
looks like we know what his purpose is
what he does we you know we know we have
stories about him we have songs that
celebrate him and we have events which
celebrate him as well and so it is
obvious that Santa Claus exists
now now the thing is that what people
tend to to struggle with is to
understand that beings are not obvious
it's not that obvious what how to
contain a being so you for example you
have parts you have hands and fingers
you have you know you have toes you have
eyes you have hair you have all these
different parts okay and there is
something your being your personhood
which holds all those things together
which makes us see that those parts are
are you okay
and there are you can even add things to
you which make us see that that
participate in your person you can get a
tattoo you can women can wear makeup you
know I can also cut my beard in a
certain way which participates in my
person I can even put on clothing a
certain style of clothing which at some
point will participate in my being even
though it's not completely attached to
my body it's still part of who I am as a
person okay so I have these parts and
there's something which brings those
parts together
okay now Santa Claus is the same thing
first of all he has elements of his
person which manifests his being who
Santa Claus is we all know who Santa
Claus is we all know you know what what
what he represents with with his
purposes and those with his body let's
say Santa Claus his body is just not as
contained as your body it is actually a
lot bigger than your body and so there
are parts of Santa Claus are the images
of Santa Claus that we see in Walmart
that we see in in movies that we see in
in in different you know different songs
different stories just like your picture
which appears online or your picture
that's in your telephone or in some
family
also is an extension of you right when
people see the picture they recognize
you and they come into contact with you
like so - Santa Claus has parts so when
you when a guy dresses up as Santa Claus
in your mall he is manifesting Santa
Claus right he is a part of Santa Claus
to the extent that he's participating in
the being of Santa Claus at that moment
okay
now Santa Claus is actually a great
example because you can actually speak
to Santa Claus now when you go into the
mall you sit you know if a child goes to
the mall they sit on Santa Clauses lap
and then they speak to Santa Claus what
will they do they will tell Santa Claus
the Santa Claus will ask them oh my
young child what would you like for
Christmas and the child will answer what
they want for Christmas and Santa Claus
will find some story about how you know
he's gonna try to get that child his
gifts for Christmas okay so the child is
speaking to Santa Claus and that's
really important to understand the child
is not speaking to Joe to the Joe under
the costume who's put on the fig beard
she she isn't speaking to him she's
speaking to Santa Claus and it also
isn't Joe that is answering it's Santa
Claus that is answering because Joe is
not gonna tell the little child about
his recent divorce or about how his
girlfriend left him with his best friend
and how he's in the ruts right now and
that's why he's taking the stupid Santa
Claus job for Christmas he's not going
to say that no he's going to smile he's
going to laugh and he's going to tell
the child about what gifts he they're
gonna get for Christmas if Joe starts to
tell the child something else starts to
talk about something else
about maybe his new car you know you
just bought this new car and he's making
his car payments the child will no
longer recognize Santa Claus that person
Joe will cease to be a body part of
Santa Claus
now you can write a letter to Santa
Claus you can write a letter Santa Claus
North Pole put it in the mail send it to
Santa Claus then you know what Santa
Claus is going to answer
and it isn't Martha sitting in the post
office you know typing out the letter
she's not the one who's actually
answering she is manifesting Santa Claus
okay you can do the same thing you're
doing to Santa Claus I can do to you I
can say when you answer my question I
can take well it's not you that he's
answering my question right it's your
mouth that's answering my question but
is that is that true is it your mouth
that's answering the question no your
mouth is the tool by which you are
answering the question and so to the
disguised Santa Clauses that go to the
mall are the tool by which Santa Claus
manifests himself in the world Santa
Claus is a being that's pretty coherent
you can he has a personality he has a
way of speaking you can engage with
Santa Claus and Santa Claus will answer
and this is not this is not just
imaginary because you are not that
contained as you think you as a person
you can be possessed by all these
different ideas you can be influenced by
all these external influences and even
in your mind you are not as centered as
you think you have all these different
kind of crazy personalities that can
pull you in different directions so why
do you think that you as a person exists
right there is something there is a
total way in which those elements are
pulled together into a consistent being
if it wasn't so we'd say you're
schizophrenic or we'd say you're crazy
if you're not crazy there's something
pulling those elements together so that
when I ask you something
right you answer me I recognize you in
that answer okay now I want to tell you
a story about about the about the tooth
fairy
because the the manner in which the
tooth fairy exists is also very
interesting to help someone understand
what exactly it is we're talking about
when we talk about spiritual beings and
how they can
in the world now my daughter you know I
I grew up in a in a kind of Protestant
home and so in my house we didn't
believe in Santa Claus the way that
other families did so I kind of kept
that that's a habit and so in our family
with my kids we don't we didn't we
didn't tell them that Santa Claus
existed in the same manner that their
uncle existed or their aunt or whatever
we we treated it as a game you know
something to celebrate something to tell
stories about something to to have fun
with and and and celebrate and enjoy and
we did the same with the tooth fairy so
I never pretended that there was an
actual physical fairy that came into my
my child's house to put a tooth under
her pillow but we did talk about the
truth there we talked about the tooth
fairy and we talked about the story of
the tooth fairy and I you know I would
kind of joke around with them and say oh
the tooth fairy is gonna come and bring
money unput him under your pillow and I
and I thought that they knew that that
physically the physical cause of the -
of the money getting under the pillow
was me you know but then when my
daughter I forget how old she was I
think she was like seven or eight maybe
one day she she lost her tooth and she
was gonna put her tooth under her pillow
and then I I said something because I
wasn't being careful at all and I said
something you know to the effect of how
I I had to make sure I don't forget to
you know to do put the money into the
pillow and and and something like that
and then she looked at me you know with
these eyes like like I had like she was
devastated because I had I had uh kind
of ruined the magic I guess you know of
what kind of other families do it and
she looked at me with those eyes and she
said what she said the Tooth Fairy
doesn't exist and I looked at her and I
realized that you know I maybe I had
been careful enough and that she really
had entered into this you know
full-throttle and so I thought for a
second but it didn't take me very long
to to ask her a few questions to kind of
help her understand what was going on
and I
I asked her I said why do you think that
you know I would put money under your
pillow and my daughter said well because
you know I lost my tooth so you know you
put them under my pillow but obviously
that is not direct causality there's no
why would you put money under a pillow
because of the two that said why would I
so I asked I said why would I put money
under your pillow because you lost your
tooth because I mean obviously that's
not it's not that an immediate aha thing
it's not it's not that obvious and then
she said well you're doing it because of
the Tooth Fairy and so that's what I
asked her I said so what you're saying
what you're telling me is that the
reason why I put money under your pillow
is because of the tooth fairy so the
Tooth Fairy is making me put money under
your pillow
and she looked at me and it's so funny
because you think you know
seems like me even adults don't
understand how that works but she
totally got it and she totally
understood what I was talking about and
I just saw she had just smile on her
face it's like she she had just
discovered a little mystery of how the
universe exists uh and then it was
really fascinating because I don't
remember why but for some reason she had
to do the same like I think someone her
friend or I forget who had also lost her
tooth and then she was the one who was
going to put the money under the pillow
and she was so excited like she was so
happy that she could be the one putting
the money under the pillow for the tooth
fairy you know and realizing that it was
because of the Tooth Fairy that she was
doing that um so I think that that can
that can help people understand to what
how beings function what it means for
something to be a being what it means
when we talk about the notion that
certain cities have certain
personalities that certain cities have
certain elements which make them unique
make them something and you can then
understand why in the Bible we have this
notion of the angels of different cities
how different cities have different
angels because a city can say something
a city can speak coherently can say
things which make you recognize that it
is that City which is speaking to you
okay now once again you you obviously
cannot take it at the first degree you
have to undo have to be able to pierce
the mystery of understanding how these
beings you know stack up in a hierarchy
and how you know how you are also made
of parts just like a city is made of
parts and your uniqueness is no
different from the uniqueness of a city
which has its own personality its own
way of speaking and you can hear a city
speak you can you know just not it's not
it's not it's not a superstitious thing
at all just like you can hear a country
speak just like you can hear
higher-level beings you can you can you
can encounter them you can encounter
them and and hear them okay just like
you can encounter Santa Claus in the
mall by looking at Joe who's dressed up
as Santa Claus you are in that moment
encountering Santa Claus you are hearing
Santa Claus okay and you'll say we know
that's just silly that's just absurd but
yeah you do you you and you do that all
the time when you encounter a police
officer or you encounter a judge or you
encounter any official representative of
a city or of an entity that judge is is
not
going to represent to you his own
personal proclivities and when he does
that we're in trouble
some people are seeing that happen now
seeing how the judges instead of just
manifesting the law you know they're
inserting all their as much as as
possible their opinions into what
they're saying but in a normal
functioning world if if let's say if a
city holds together if a if a country or
you know a state holds together the
representatives of that state are there
to manifest to you the will of that
state based on its identity its
Constitution its laws and so when you
hear a judge speaking you are actually
speaking to the city the state that you
are encountering to a certain extent
when you pray to a judge you are praying
to the state which the judge is supposed
to manifest and the judges answer is the
answer of the state there is no other
answer besides that right you can maybe
appeal to a higher level authority but
it that's that it doesn't matter even if
you appeal to a higher level authority
you are appealing to something which
manifests the state more and more purely
the law of the state more and more
purely okay and so you can pray to the
angel hahahaha man some people are gonna
freak out at this but you can speak to
the spirit of the United States and you
can hear the spirit of the United States
speak through its representative through
its images through its truth through you
know through both its cultural images
but also its formal legal
representatives and that is just how the
world works and so atheists seriously
Santa Claus exists you know the Tooth
Fairy exists there are beings that exist
that exist different from a rock so all
right I hope that helps you understand
if not leave all your angry atheist
comments below and all your your your
silly superstitious accusations below
but I I have to say that I would make
the effort to on
stand because it is possible that it is
not me who is making a fool of myself so
I hope you enjoyed this video my next
video is coming very soon it's going to
be an interpretation of the movie
gravity and so yeah I'll talk to you
guys soon if you enjoyed this content
and our exploration of symbolism get
involved I love to read your comments in
the comment section below please go
ahead and share this on social media to
all your friends and also please
consider supporting us financially on
patreon you'll find a link to the
patreon page in the description below